so imagine you've got an object sitting
in front of this concave mirror if you
wanted to figure out where the image is
formed you can draw ray tracings and so
one ray you can draw is a parallel ray
that goes through the focal point but
these rays are reversible i don't have
to draw that one turns out if you send
rays back along the way they came
they'll just retrace the path they came
along the other way so these rays are
reversible i send a ray parallel it gets
sent through the focal point but if i
send array through the focal point it
will get sent parallel in other words i
don't have to draw this ray i can draw
this ray right here the one that goes
from the tip of the object through the
focal point that's gonna get sent
parallel so i'm gonna draw this one just
for fun and then i'm gonna draw another
one you need to in order to find where
the image is i'll draw this one here so
this this white line is called the
principal axis it's drawn through the
center of this curved mirror i'm going
to draw a ray that goes from the tip of
the object to that center point because
i know the law of reflection says that
the angle in has to equal the angle out
and the angles are measured from the
normal line and it just so happens that
this principal axis that's usually drawn
here anyways is serving as a perfectly
good normal line for this center of the
mirror since it's passing through that
center of the mirror in a perpendicular
way i can just use that to my advantage
i know that the angle ends got to equal
the angle out i just have to make sure
that this angle out is about looks like
that about equal to the angle that it
came in at so these two have to be the
same angle theta and now i can find
where my image is the image of this
object is going to be at the point where
they cross so the tip of this object
gets mapped to this point right here and
we get an image that's upside down and
it looks like that so ray tracing is
cool it lets you find where the image is
but i mean i just kind of eyeballed this
angle here this might have been off by a
little bit it might have been off by a
degree or two if i wanted to get exactly
where the image is i'd want an equation
that i could just plug into in other
words that i can plug into how far was
the object from the mirror and how long
is this focal length and it would spit
out exactly where the image is going to
be so that's what we're going to derive
in this video it's called the mirror
equation and it'll tell us how to relate
the object distance the image distance
and the focal length so let's do this
how do you derive it if you look in the
textbook it looks complicated it's not
actually as bad as it looks when i used
to look at it the first time i was like
this is some sort of mathematical
witchcraft i don't want to deal with but
it's not nearly as bad as it looks we're
going to start with drawing triangles so
we'll notice that these two angles are
the same we're going to use this to our
advantage so we're going to make two
triangles that have these as one of
their angles so the first one let's
consider this one let's say one of the
triangles will be from the base of this
image to the center of the mirror and
then from the mirror to the tip of the
image and then from the tip of the image
back down to the base of the image so
imagine this pink triangle right here
it's a right triangle because that angle
right here is a right angle and it's got
theta as one of its angles but i could
draw another triangle that has this
angle theta i can go from the tip of the
object to the center of the mirror and
then from the center of the mirror to
the base of the object and then from the
base of the object to the tip of the
object and i get this blue triangle
that's also a right triangle since this
angle here is a right angle so in other
words these triangles are similar they
both have an angle theta they both have
a right angle or in other words if that
if you don't like similar triangles just
think about it this way you could use a
trig function pick your favorite trig
function i'm going to pick tangent so
let's take tangent theta i know tangent
theta by definition is always the
opposite over the adjacent the opposite
to this angle would we'll take this
angle down here first the opposite to
that theta is this side what does that
side mean that's the height of the image
so i'm going to call that h i for image
height that's how tall the image is so i
know that this is going to equal height
of the image divided by the adjacent
side to this angle here is this distance
right here and we're going to give that
a name that's just how far the image is
from the mirror so we give this a name
we call this distance from the mirror to
the image we call that the image
distance and it's measured from the
center of the mirror so not from like
this end right here this little tip part
but from wherever the center of the
mirror is it's measured from this point
right here and that's this adjacent side
since this is how far that image is from
the center of the mirror so i'll call
that d i since it's the image distance
but that was for this theta down here i
know that tangent of theta this is also
a theta up here i can use the same
relationship for this theta and i know
that tangent of this theta also has to
be opposite over adjacent but the
opposite of this theta is this side
right here and what is that side that's
just the height of the object so i'll
call that h0 that's the object height so
the opposite side for this theta is the
object height and then you divide by
what you divide by the adjacent side
that's just going to be this distance
from the mirror to the object we'll give
that a name and if you guessed object
distance then you guessed right this is
going to be the object distance and
again we measure it from the center of
the mirror not some curved portion that
sticks out over here but from the center
part of the mirror so that's the
adjacent side to this theta down here so
i'm going to write that as d o and so
this is an important relationship this
is actually given a name just by itself
this isn't the equation we're hunting
for but it's so important it gets its
own name just part of this derivation
gets its own name it's called the
magnification equation but it's usually
not written this way people usually
write it as h i and then they divide by
h o so you get h i divided by h o equals
and then you multiply both sides by d i
you get d i over d o so a lot of times
this is called the magnification
equation it gives you a way to find what
the height of the image is so we were
looking for a way to find how far the
image is from the mirror but this lets
you figure out okay you also need to
know how big is it going to be so if we
solve this for the height of the image
we get height of the images the height
of the object times some factor and that
factor is just going to be the image
distance divided by the object distance
here's the thing though look at this
image got flipped over so if we define
this image distance as positive if it's
on the same side as the object we get a
flipped over image that'd be like a
negative height so since we want to
represent flipped over images with a
negative value we actually write this
equation down with a negative inside of
here we say that the height of the image
is equal to negative h0 di over do or
you could put the negative up here too
so we stick a negative over here that
way we know that if you get a negative
value for the image height you know it's
flipped over so in other words if the
value i got for h i was negative three
centimeters that means i'd get an image
that had a height of three centimeters
but it'd be flipped over and that's what
the negative represents okay so that's
kind of a side note this is not what
we're trying to derive we're trying to
derive a formula that would give us the
image distance based on object distance
and focal length so we need to do
another set of triangles so what we'll
do now is instead of considering these
thetas here we'll consider these angles
here now i can't call them theta because
we already called those theta so i'll
call these phi so these angles also have
to be the same because anytime you have
a line and then you cut another line
through it these angles here will always
be the same so we could do the same game
we could play the same game we played
for theta with these phi's we'll form
two triangles each triangle is going to
have phi as one of the angles so for the
first one we'll do this object height as
one side over here to the base of phi
and then back up over to here and then
for the other one we need to also have a
triangle that has phi in it so we'll do
this from here to here down to there and
then back up to phi so we've got two
triangles this triangle and this
triangle and they both have phi and they
both have a right angle so these are
also similar triangles in other words
we'll play the same game we'll say that
tangent of this phi is going to have to
equal the opposite over the adjacent the
opposite to this phi is this side which
is just h o so we can write h o divided
by the adjacent now is not d o because
this side only goes to here it doesn't
go the whole way to the mirror it only
goes that far so that's the entire
object distance minus this piece right
over here so if i subtracted this much
from the object distance i'd get the
remaining amount which is the adjacent
part of this triangle so this distance
from the mirror to the focal point is
given a name it's called the focal
length and we represent it with an f so
a little confusing because f represents
both a point and it represents the
length from the mirror to that point so
f is going to represent that length as
well so this adjacent side we could
write as the object distance minus the
focal length since this remaining part
right here is the adjacent side which is
object distance minus the focal length
but we know that this phi is also equal
to this phi so i can do tangent of theta
for this phi the opposite side would now
be this side what is that what is this
side of the triangle that's just equal
to the height of the image this side is
the same as the image height so i can
say that this whole thing tangent to phi
has to equal opposite over adjacent this
time the opposite of phi is the image
height and we divide by this distance
right here which is just the focal
length so this adjacent side for this
triangle is simply the focal length so
i'll just divide by f and so what i've
got are two equations that i'm going to
put together and we will get the mirror
equation out of this there's different
ways to proceed at this point what i'm
going to do is i don't want h o or h i
in either of these so i'm just going to
solve this one here for h o over h i and
i get h o over h i so imagine dividing
both sides by h i and then multiplying
both sides by d o minus f and i'd get h
o over h i equals d o
minus f the focal length divided by the
focal length but i could do the same
thing up here i can get h o over h i is
just going to equal d o over d i since
all you have to do is divide both sides
by h i and then multiply both sides by d
o but this left hand side right here is
the same as this left hand side right
here so we know that h o over h i
already equals d o minus f over f and up
here we know that h o over h i equals d
o over d i so that means that d o minus
f over f has to also equal d o over d i
since both of these expressions equal h
o over h i so we can set them all equal
because they're all equal to the same
thing h o over h i and now we're going
to solve this we're just going to clean
it up the left hand side i can write
i'll just stop using colors here the
left hand side is going to be d o over f
minus 1 since f over f just equals one
and that's got to equal d o over d i and
now we can divide both sides by d o if i
divide both sides by d o i get one over
f since the d o cancels minus one over d
o equals and then the d o will cancel
with this d o on top and i just get one
over d i and now we made it except it's
usually written with this one over d o
added on the right if we add one over d
o to both sides we finally get the
expression we wanted which is one over
the object distance plus one over the
image distance equals one over the focal
length it's a pretty simple formula it
took a little bit of effort to get to
this but this is called the mirror
equation and it relates the focal length
of the mirror to the image distance and
the object distance in other words if
you know how far you put the object from
the mirror and you know the focal length
of the mirror this lets you figure out
exactly where the image distance is
instead of just kind of eyeballing it
and using a protractor this will let you
solve for where that image is exactly
and if you couple it with this
magnification equation up here you can
also figure out the exact height of the
image now you might be feeling a little
sketchy about this negative sign i mean
i kind of threw it in quick over here
what what's going on with this negative
in fact how do we know if any of this
stuff is negative or positive well the
convention that i use that a lot of
textbooks use now is the one where focal
lengths will be positive for concave
mirrors just like this mirror right here
this is a concave mirror but if it was
bent the other way if the mirror looked
like this it'd be a convex mirror and
that would be a negative focal length
and it kind of makes sense if the mirror
was bent this way the focal point is
kind of back this way which is kind of
behind it so it makes sense that it's
sort of negative and the object distance
over here if it's on the same side as
your eye if you're using this correctly
your eye should be over on this side you
would see an object right here but you'd
also see an image of that object right
here and if this object is on the same
side as the mirror as your eye which it
should be then this object distance is
positive it's basically always positive
unless you've got some double set of
mirrors or something weird happening if
you got a single mirror there's no
craziness going on this this object
distance is just always defined to be
positive using the conventions that
we're using up here and again there are
other conventions you can use but this
is the one used in a lot of textbooks
these days the di is a little trickier
the di is also positive if that image is
on the same side as your eye like it is
right here so this image would be
considered a positive image distance
since it's on this side if the image got
formed on this side of the mirror so you
formed an image right here that would be
a negative image distance if this was
five centimeters behind the mirror we'd
consider that a negative five centimeter
image distance and if you use that
convention with this mirror equation
you'll get a correct relationship
between the object distance image
distance and the focal length and if you
use that same sign convention with this
magnification equation you'll also get
the exact height of the image and if
that image height comes out negative
you'll know that it got flipped upside
down and if the image height comes out
positive you know that the image will
stay right side up so recapping using a
bunch of similar triangles we were able
to derive a mirror equation that relates
the object distance image distance and
focal length and along the way we derive
the magnification equation that relates
the heights of the image and object to
the distances of the image and object
and you have to be very careful with
signs even though the object distance is
basically always positive focal length
can be positive or negative focal length
will be positive for concave mirrors and
it'll be negative for convex mirrors
image distances will be positive if
they're on the same side of the mirror
as your eye if they're in front of the
mirror but they'll be negative if
they're behind the mirror and again this
is not the only sign convention you
could use but it's as good as any other
science convention and it's the one used
in a lot of textbooks these days